existe-t-il un racisme anti blanc alors
vous sylvie vous dites oui puisque vous
dites que vous avez subi des insultes
on vous disait salle blanche ici on veut
pas de blanc sale [ __ ] dégagé ouais
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait
je revenais d'un week-end chez mes
parents qui habitent à pierrefitte sur
seine saint denis et ma fille et moi on
allait tranquillement vers la gare pour
reprendre le train et on a été agressé
par un groupe de jeunes a priori parce
qu'on les a pas vraiment bien vu et ils
nous ont ils ont commencé par nous
lancer une barre de fer donc on s'est
retourné en disant mais enfin c'est
dangereux qu'est ce que vous faites on
s'est pris une pluie de cailloux on
s'est pris les insultes donc ça le
blanche sale [ __ ] on veut pas de blancs
ici et ça s'est terminé par un bout de
béton lancer qui a atteint la tête de ma
fille et qui a eu donc cinq points de
suture au crâne
alors oui c'est extrêmement choquant et
comment elle va votre fils maintenant
alors elle a été très traumatisée
pendant très longtemps elle ne voulait
plus aller chez ses grands parents parce
qu'elle avait peur et bon elle elle
commence à accepter mais elle est
toujours un peu sur la défensive ne
passe plus jamais dans cette rue elle a
quel âge elle a 27 ans maintenant alors
mais pourquoi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au départ
pourquoi ça ça a dégénéré comme ça il
s'est rien passé on marchait
tranquillement dans la rue on allait à
la gare ont discuté toutes les deux
ensemble ça vraiment il y avait aucune
raison on a parlé à personne on a croisé
par ces jeunes nous ont interpellé dire
il était dans la cité qui était à côté
du trottoir et directement ils nous ont
insultés
j'ai été extrêmement choqué ce que vous
nous aviez dit oui très choquée parce
que moi j'ai grandi là oui j'y suis
arrivé à l'âge de 4 ans j'ai grandi là
je suis allé à l'école maternelle à
l'école primaire au collège
j'en suis j'ai quitté le chez mes
parents j'avais 25 ans donc j'ai fait
toute ma vie de jeune femme là bas est
jamais j'avais été confronté à ça et par
rapport à ce que quelqu'un disait tout à
l'heure je pense qu'effectivement on se
préoccupait pas avant de savoir quelle
était la religion des gens on était amis
et voilà et c'était tout on se
préoccupait de sap à savoir si il était
juif il était noir c'était on
s'entendait bien points suivis
vous je le vois vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs un guetteur justement
puisqu'il vous vous dites que vous avez
grandi dans ces quartiers vous ne les
reconnaissait plus la population a
changé
vous sentez une violence une fermeture
d'esprit qui sont installés depuis
depuis combien de temps alors moi ça
fait très longtemps que j'ai quitté ce
cet endroit puisque je vis dans le val
de marne maintenant mais c'est surtout
je pense une urbanisation démesurée avec
des immeubles qui ont poussé comme des
champignons où les gens peuvent se
donner la main d'une fenêtre à l'autre
il n'y a pas de verdure il n'y a pas d'
espaces il ya des voitures partout les
gens ont les balcons qui donne sur la
nationale et je pense que quand on ne
peut pas avoir un espace de tranquillité
et un espace un peu de sérénité
ça peut engendrer que de la violence
suivie quand on vous dit salle blanche
on veut pas de blancs ici qu'est ce que
vous dites dans votre tête vous est ce
que ça peut vous faire devenir raciste
des phrases comme ça non je pense pas
par contre ben je fasse je me serais
jamais permis de tenir ce genre de
propos envers quelqu'un d'autre d'une
autre couleur ou d'une autre religion
que la mienne hawks et je suis très
choqué qu'on puisse tenir ce genre de
propos envers quelqu'un d'autre mais
raciste non oui oui car non le
témoignage de sylvie une loi nous
indiquer à tous que le piège et qui nous
est tendu c'est de tomber dans un fond
de compétition des racines comme
certains veulent le faire tomber des
compétitions des mémoires il n'y a pas
de compétition des mémoires des
compétitions de l'histoire des
compétitions des racismes et il faut pas
se sentir concerné juste dans le racisme
nous touche là où on sera plus fort
c'est lorsque les uns et les autres nous
invité ce soir ont tous raconté un cas
de racisme qui les caractérise qui les a
touché au plus profond d'eux mêmes
lorsque cette france qui est en face de
nous cela fera comme un seul homme face
à tous les racismes pas contre son
racisme contre le racisme qui la
concerne
alors je pense que notre pays gagnera
cette victoire parce qu'il ya une
majorité silencieuse de français qui
n'est pas raciste il ya une minorité
agissante qui crée le trouble dans le
pays aujourd'hui
et là il faut qu'on inverse le rapport
de force cette majorité silencieuse elle
doit se faire entendre
elle doit dire ce qui est inacceptable
autant celui de hassan ii sylvie
des trois autres parce que moi je pense
que encore une fois les valeurs de notre
pays nous y oblige les valeurs d'un pays
nous dit nous dit parrot payez vous sur
vous-même et définissez vous par
d'origine comme battait quand les
injustices qui vous concerne les valeurs
de notre pays la république sociale qu
évoquer notre ministre tout à l'heure
c'est une république sociale qui nous
appartient à tous et pas à certains
comme même un député connu a voulu le
dire la république ce n'est pas lui ce
n'est pas vous ça n'est pas moi c'est
nous tous si on arrive effectivement à
intégrer ça dans l'éducation mais plus
largement qu'on en parle dans nos
familles dans nos groupes d'amis et
construisent un moment donné qu'il faut
sortir de ces préjugés de ce repli de
ses tentations
j'ai envie de dire de désespérance alors
effectivement on va s'élever va se
mettre au dessus on a transcendé ce que
nous sommes bien sûr nous sommes tous
rattachés un lien naturel
une histoire une culture une religion ou
pas parce que la liberté de conscience
et croit ou pas il faut qu'on dépasse à
un moment donné pour aller vers des
valeurs universelles qui nous concerne
tous quels que soient nos origines si on
arrive à faire ça
sylvie hassan et les autres franchement
on va les mettre ko